Précédemment sur dtc
décembre 2016 je décide de me faire tatouer
mais ça tourne mal...
putain mais c'est quoi ça !
février 2017 je commençais séances de laser pour me débarrasser du tatouage
une séance
Deux
Trois
Quatre
cinq
six
sept séances
Juin 2018 je décide de changer de méthode
Voilà donc après un an et sept séances de laser Q-Switch classique j'ai décidé de passer la vitesse supérieure
avec le laser picosure qui est le laser de dernière génération pour ça j'ai pris rendez-vous au centre
saint-honoré ponthieu dans le 8e arrondissement à Paris donc on va faire comment fait d'habitude j'y vais
vous me suivez et puis je reviens et en débrief allez c'est parti
Alors la première différence par rapport à d'habitude c'est que cette fois on m'a mis de la pommade anesthésiante
Bon ça oblige est arrivé un petit peu en avance parce qu'après il faut attendre une heure pour que la pommade agisse.
Donc bha j'ai attendu
J'ai attendu le j'ai attendu
J'ai attendu une heure hein donc
Mais...
ça valait le coup
Je sens un peu mais vraiment c'est heu sans commune mesure
Heuuuu
Ha bha j'ai moins chaud que la dernière fois
Voilà c'est fini mais alors comme vous avez pu le voir c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins douloureux que les séances précédentes
je vais me poser chez moi et on débrief tout ça
alors on va commencer par le début donc le laser picosure c'est quoi la différence ?
bon c'est un laser qui est plus puissant que celui que j'avais utilisé jusqu'à présent
à la base la technique c'est la même c'est à dire c'est un faisceau laser donc c'est à dire de la lumière
amplifié qui va venir cogner contre les fragments d'encre de pigments du tatouage pour la faire exploser
jusqu'à ce que les particules soit suffisamment petites pour être
évacués par le corps
avec le premier laser que j'avais utilisé c'est à dire le Q-switch classique qui est celui qu'on retrouve le plus communément dans les centres de
détatouage les impulsions elles étaient de l'ordre de la nanoseconde c'est à dire en gros un
milliardième de seconde alors c'est déjà des impulsions ultracourtes
mais là avec le pico jour on est de l'ordre de la picoseconde
d'où son nom
une picoseconde c'est un millième de milliardième de seconde
et en gros avantage c'est qu'avec cette méthode la destruction de l'encre elle est plus
mécanique que thermique, c'est à dire que en gros
ça chauffe moins mais ça cogne plus fort sur les pigments et donc cette petite précision
est en fait comme vous l'avez vu sur les images j'ai eu beaucoup moins mal que d'habitude
alors bon ça picote ça picote plus ou moins selon les zones et il y à des endroits où c'est plus sensible mais c'est vraiment sans comparaison
il paraît que le picosure et moins douloureux que le Q-switch classique
moi je peux pas juger parce que là contrairement aux fois précédentes on m'a mis de la pommade
anesthésiante donc c'est notamment pour ça que j'ai très très peu senti donc mon conseil est déjà si vous faites dé-tatoués un jour
exigez qu'on vous mette de la pommade anesthésiante sauf
vous aimez tout ce qui est douleur si vous aimez souffrir
alors deux autres avantages annoncés du picosure parce qu'évidemment
on jugera tous ensemble si les promesses sont tenues c'est que d'abord il faut moins de séances
que avec le classique pour se débarrasser du tatouage là on m'a annoncé quatre séances
et puis aussi il ya besoin d'attendre moins longtemps entre deux séances à dire qu'avec l'autre c'était deux mois là c'est tous les mois
pourquoi parce qu'en fait le laser est censé être moins agressif
avec la avec la peau
donc on cicatrice plus rapidement donc on peut y retourner plus vite
donc on récapitule on a un nouveau laser
qui est censée être plus efficace que le précédent
un nouveau tarif puisque la c'est 300 euros la séance
au lieu de 150 mais avec moins de séance a priori une séance par mois pendant
quatre mois ce qui veut dire que vous allez voir mon fessier régulièrement cet été et le verdict ce sera pour la rentrée
mais bon je vais pas vous faire languir plus longtemps hein je sais pourquoi vous êtes là le moment que vous attendiez toutes et tous
les photos
alors ça c'est le tatouage juste avant la séance ça c'est le tatouage
juste après le laser ça c'est le tatouage le lendemain
ça c'est le tatouage deux jours après
ça c'est le tatouage
trois jours après et ça c'est le tatouage au bout de quatre jours
attention c'est trop tôt on est d'accord pour juger de l'efficacité du laser
alors pour deux raisons on en a déjà parlé mais je vous refais la petite petite explication
imaginez que les
particules d'encre dans les pigments sous la peau c'est des petits bouts de charbon savez comme ce qu'on met dans le dans le barbecue
le médecin il a tapé dessus avec son petit marteau au laser et il a réduit certains pigments en poudre il faut le temps
déjà que cette poudre soit évacué donc ça se voit pas
immédiatement contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire en regardant des vidéos de  dé-tatouages sur internet
et puis aussi bas il ya des morceaux de charbon qui sont plus denses plus résistants que les que les autres donc cela
il faut y retourner pour taper dessus voilà c'est pour ça qu'il ya besoin de plusieurs séances dont ce qu'on va faire c'est que
j'y retourne dans un mois dont on jugera tous ensemble à ce moment-là de l'efficacité du truc et puis bon bah évidemment on jugera
séance après séance puisque là comme avec l'ancien laser il a commencé doucement et il va
augmenter un peu la puissance
au fur et à mesure des rendez vous donc vous avez compris on se retrouve dans un mois pour une nouvelle séance de laser
on verra bien
d'ici là je ne vais pas vous plantez on va continuer à faire des vidéos
donc en attendant qu'est ce qu'on fait je vous en supplie  mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous bien